[Applaudissements]
vous savez comme dans cette campagne
salle après salle on entre avec françois
xavier il ya évidemment de l'émotion
pour nous mais il ya une profonde
gratitude une gratitude pour vous qui
nous avez accompagné pendant la totalité
de cette campagne une gratitude pour
vous qui répondait présent une gratitude
pour vous qui avez redonné à la droite
et au centre son enthousiasme et quand
on rentre dans cette salle et consomme
vous êtes là pas pour nous mais pour les
convictions qu'on partage pour ce que
nous menons ensemble avec
françois-xavier avec toute la liste
c'est le plus beau des encouragements et
je voulais dire à françois xavier à quel
point chaque jour tout au long de cette
campagne
je suis fier du choix que nous avons
fait ensemble ensemble parce que je lui
ai proposé est ensemble parce qu'il l'a
accepté
françois-xavier n'apporte pas seulement
du renouvellement il n'apporte pas
seulement une nouvelle génération les
nouveaux talents que je veux faire
émerger
il apporte plus il apporte l'incarnation
cette droite de valeur à laquelle je
crois j'ai toujours profondément cru on
ne reconstruira pas la droite et le
centre en baissant les regards j'ai
toujours profondément cru que ça n'était
pas un destin pour notre famille
politique de marcher à l'ombre et j'ai
toujours profondément cru que l'on
pouvait affirmer ses convictions et le
faire en rassemblant regarder et
n'oubliez pas cette leçon de notre
campagne nous avons fait le choix
d'affirmer nos convictions et nous le
faisons en étant tous rassemblés ça
n'est pas quand nous reculons que tu
n'aurais youn on sait quand nous
affirmons nos idées que nous sommes
capables de nous fédérer tous les uns et
les autres
et regardez notre famille politique ce
soir comme elle est rassemblée portées
par des personnalités qui ont des
talents aussi divers et dont on peut
être fier à l'image d'agnès d'arnaud de
frédéric de geoffroy de nadine ou de
brice il ya dans cette salle nos élus
locaux les élus parisiens les élus
franciliens nos élus départementaux
régionaux
nos parlementaires autour de annie et de
brigitte ceux qui font la force d'une
famille politique qui n'a pas oublié que
pour faire de la politique il faut être
enraciné et que le nouveau monde n'a pas
de supériorité sur l'ancien monde parce
que quand l'on veut aller quelque part
il faut savoir d'où l'on vient et tout
au long de cette campagne comme ce soir
encore ils ont été de plus en plus
nombreux à nous apporter leur soutien je
veux remercier sincèrement valérie de sa
présence ce soir elle qui fait un
travail énorme dans sa région
merci à toi valérie je veux remercier
hervé avec lequel nous avons fondé une
union durable celle de la droite et du
centre que nous avons rebâti qui nous a
toujours porté et qui nous amènera les
victoires de demain
merci à toi hervé merci à loïc merci à
philippe merci à sylvie je veux
remercier christian qui est l'image même
de ce qu'est la fidélité politique à une
famille qui a des valeurs
celui qui n'a jamais tergiverser jamais
négocié
je veux remercier bruno kern colonne
vertébrale et qui a été si solides au
moment des attaques contre françois
fillon
merci à toi bruno je veux remercier
gérard larcher qui a redonné toute sa
place au sénat face aux attaques du
président de la république je veux
remercier joseph qui est notre fierté et
qui a rappelé ici ce soir que la seule
famille politique qui porte l'union de
l'europe là où emmanuel macron la
fragmente c'est celle des républicains
c'est celle du ppe c'est celle de
l'union de la droite et du centre
et je voudrais enfin rendre hommage à
deux personnes qui ont énormément compté
pour moi et qui m'ont fait la
gentillesse d'être présent ce soir je
veux rendre hommage à michèle alliot
marie et à edouard balladur
merci à vous merci à vous monsieur le
premier nous je mesure ce que signifie
votre présence merci
eh bien oui notre famille n'est jamais
aussi forte que quand elle est
rassemblée ce soir elle les rassembler
dans cette campagne
elle les rassembler et c'est une des
dynamiques qui nous a été apporté tout
au long de cette campagne des
européennes le président de la
république le premier ministre
la tête de liste en marche
n'ont de cesse dans cette campagne de
montrer leur mépris pour la france de
droite le premier ministre
encore hier s'en est pris à ce qu'il
appelle la droite trocadéro une droite
trocadéro qu'il a expliqué ne pas aimer
mais ce n'est pas la droite trocadéro
qu'il n'aime pas c'est la droite tout
court qu'il n'aime pas parce que ce
qu'ils font ce qu'ils portent ce qu'ils
croient ne correspond en rien aux
convictions et aux visions de la droite
quand on est de droite
on a le courage de baisser la dépense
publique et de revenir sur le nombre de
fonctionnaires comme nicolas sarkozy
avait su le faire quand on est de droite
on ne nie pas l'existence d'une culture
française et on abaisse pas notre pays à
l'étranger en disant que la france
n'aurait commis que des crimes contre
l'humanité comme le président a pu le
faire en algérie quand on est de droite
on ne confond pas le voile islamique et
le fichu qu aurait pu porter nos grands
mères à l'église comme le fait madame
loiseau quand on est de droite
on a du respect pour nos aînés et on ne
prend pas huit milliards d'euros aux
retraités comme le président de la
république l'a fait en moins de deux ans
en expliquant que les retraités étaient
des privilégiés
[Applaudissements]
quand on est de droite on n'accepte pas
de faire rentrer année après année
toujours plus d'émigrés alors que l'on
sait que nos capacités d'intégration
sont dépassés
quand on est de droite on ne compare pas
un terroriste palestinien à nelson
mandela comme l'a fait pascal durand qui
est en position éligible sur la liste en
marge
[Applaudissements]
quand on est de droite on n'est pas
soutenu par cohn bendit
elisabeth guigou on n'envisage pas de
créer un groupe avec les socialistes
mes amis ce soir je m'adresse à tous les
français à tous ceux qui croient dans
les valeurs de la droite et du centre
dans cette élection vous pouvez faire
entendre votre voix
il y à une liste qui croient dans
l'europe il y à une liste qui porte ces
valeurs
une europe qui protège nos frontières
une europe qui défende son identité ses
racines chrétiennes face à l'islamisme
une europe des projets l'europe que nous
aimons cette liste c'est celle des
républicains de l'union de la droite et
du centre
sept doigts ça n'était évidemment pas
celle du rassemblement national
je combats à marine le pen dans cette
élection parce que le projet que porte
marine le pen est un projet de
déconstruction de l'europe et de l'euro
et que je suis convaincu que ce serait
la pire erreur à commettre pour notre
pays à un moment où nous avons besoin de
l'europe face à la chine face aux états
unis face à l'immigration massive face à
l'islamisme
face à la dérégulation climatique le
projet que porte marine le pen de
déconstruction de l'europe serait un
projet funeste pour l'avenir de notre
pays
mais cela ne signifie pas pour autant
que le seul choix soit pour ou contre
l'europe qu'elle est l'europe que
propose emmanuel macron son europe c'est
l'europe de l'élargissement sans cesse
plus loin son europe c'est celle du
multiculturalisme son europe c'est celle
de l' immigration non maîtrisée sont
europe c'est celle de la technocratie ça
n'est pas à cette europe que je crois il
y a une autre europe
il y à cette europe qui avait su faire
vivre nicolas cante sous la présidence
française de l'union européenne la
france pesait en europe et l'europe
peser dans le monde
c'est cette europe que nous nous voulons
retrouver refonder l'europe
quand nous avons réfléchi à cela avec
françois-xavier nous nous sommes dit
mais qu'est ce que cela signifie
ce n'est pas la commission européenne ce
n'est pas l'union européenne ça n'est
même pas le parlement européen qu'est ce
que c'est que l'europe
que font les pères fondateurs que
choisit style comme emblème au moment où
il fonde l'union européenne que mehdi
teale sur ce drapeau
il met les étoiles de la couronne de la
vierge
que font que font de gaulle et adenauer
quand il décide de construire cette
unité franco-allemande qu emmanuel
macron est aujourd'hui en train de
fragmenter dans quels lieux se
retrouve-t-il ils vont à la cathédrale
de reims
ils vont dans ce lieu emblématique de
l'histoire de france qui avait été
détruite par les bombardements allemands
et dans ce lieu qui dit tout de ce
qu'est notre histoire et nos racines
il repose sur les fonts baptismaux ce
que doit être l'entente et l'union de la
france et de l'allemagne
et que font-ils
comment ne pas le comprendre ce qu'ils
portent c'est de toute évidence un
projet de civilisation
ce qu'ils veulent de toute évidence
c'est dire la voix de l'europe n'est pas
éteinte
l'europe a une mission elle a quelque
chose à dire
pourquoi êtes vous là parce que la
question que nous nous posons c'est
exactement la même allons-nous accepter
silencieusement de devoir changer notre
mode de vie de renoncer à ce que nous
sommes ce qu'est notre identité notre
culture notre civilisation ou au
contraire allons nous être capable de
retrouver cette fierté de retrouver ce
souffle de retrouver cette envie
l'europe at-elle encore un destin face à
la chine et aux états unis
évidemment mais à condition de savoir
qui est laid
quand nous nous interrogeons quand on
nous demande quelle europe
voulez-vous et bien répondait que notre
liste est profondément européennes
répondait qu'elle est pour l'europe
répondait qu'elle est pour une europe
qui s'appuie sur les étangs sur les
nations et sur les frontières quelle est
pour une europe qui assume tout à la
fois son identité et sa civilisation la
civilisation ce mot magnifique que les
politiques ont renoncé à prononcer et
que nous avons voulu dans cette campagne
européenne
m au premier plan de notre projet parce
que c'est le plus beau des défis quand
on fait de la politique
[Applaudissements]
une civilisation qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une civilisation quand romulus fondre
hommes il trace un sillon parce qu'il
veut marquer clairement la différence
entre ceux qui sont dehors et ceux qui
sont à l'intérieur parce qu'il veut
clairement signifié que c'est lui et lui
seul qui choisit qui rentre à
l'intérieur de la cité
pour qu'il y ait une civilisation il
faut des limites et nous l'avons trop
oublié une de nos différences majeures
avec la liste dans marche
c'est la question de l'élargissement
nous sommes contre la poursuite de
l'élargissement parce que
l'élargissement a beaucoup trop affaibli
l'union européenne
emmanuel macron à trieste a expliqué
qu'il fallait élargir au plus vite
l'union européenne aux pays des balkans
à bucarest il a expliqué que la roumanie
et la bulgarie devait rentrer au plus
vite à l'intérieur de l'espace schengen
et comme par hasard les négociations
pour l'adhésion de l'albanie devrait
s'ouvrir en juin
vous avez vu l'engagement qu'ont signée
devant vous tous ceux qui sont sur notre
liste il s'engage à voter pendant la
durée de leur mandat contre toute
décision qui ouvrirait la voie à des
élargissements supplémentaires et à
mettre fin aux négociations avec la
turquie
[Applaudissements]
mais pour qu'il y ait des frontières il
faut les défendre
oui défendre ses frontières
ce à quoi nous avons beaucoup trop
prononcé j'aime sous-estimerait un des
drames qui se jouent en afrique
je ne sous-estimé un de ces visages
parfois hagard de gens déracinés qui ont
été poussés sur les routes de l'afrique
et de l'europe qui ont souvent connu
bien des épreuves qui ont été utilisés
instrumentalisés par les mafias de
passeurs
mais je pose juste cette question
cette question si belle que posait
charles péguy qu'est-ce qui est
meurtrier et qu'est ce qui est généreux
rien et meurtriers comme la lâcheté
rien est humain comme la fermeté quand
on laisse planer cet espoir que l'avenir
de la jeunesse africaine serait en
europe
je ne crois pas que c'est cela la vraie
générosité quand comme le fait le
gouvernement
on continue à accepter les migrants qui
viennent à travers les passeurs je ne
crois pas que c'est cela la vraie
générosité la vraie générosité c'est
celle qui consiste à dire l'avenir de la
jeunesse africaine doit être en afrique
la vocation de l'europe et de se battre
pour aider à développer le continent
africain et non pas de laisser croire
qu'on peut vider l'afrique de sa
jeunesse
[Applaudissements]
et quand le président de la république
propose de créer de nouveaux centres
d'accueil des demandeurs d'asile en
europe
nous nous proposons tout l' inverse que
les demandes soient faites hors d'europe
que des pays du moyen-orient et d'asie
assume aussi leur part de responsabilité
et qu'ils accueillent aussi des
demandeurs d'asile ce que nous demandons
c'est que quand des bateaux sont arrêtés
ils soient reconduits de l'autre côté de
la frontière et que quand quelqu'un est
rentré illégalement en europe comme
l'australie le fait
ne puisse plus jamais être régularisés
parce que l'on ne rentre pas dans une
maison en fracturant la porte
nous devons retrouver la maîtrise de
notre émigration une civilisation pour
qu'il y ait une civilisation il faut un
projet un projet ce ne sont pas des
normes
ces petites normes qui agace énerve et
bêtes dont parlait dogville il faut des
projets des projets qui parle
pourquoi l'europe pourquoi la commission
européenne plutôt que d'avoir cette
compétence normative ne se verrait-elle
pas dotés de compétences permettant de
faire avancer des vrais projets cette
europe des projets dans laquelle nous
croyons
pourquoi la france qui se croient
toujours si intelligent tu rajoutes tels
des normes supplémentaires aux normes
bruxelloises car nous avons souvent une
lourde responsabilité dans cette folie
normative je voudrais vous donner un
exemple
toute famille qui a connu l'épreuve
d'alzheimer c'est à quel point c'est une
épreuve terrible comme petit à petit
vous sentez partir l'être cher comme
petit
petit les souvenirs que l'on avait en
commun s'efface j'ai perdu ma grand mère
comme ça et chaque jour qui passe et est
un jour qui privait un tout petit peu
plus de la possibilité juste de garder
ce qui est plus précieux quand on est à
la fin les souvenirs communs des moments
heureux
alzheimer c'est une épreuve
psychologique si une épreuve morale
c'est une épreuve physique
c'est une épreuve qui emporte tout aussi
bien quand on est à la fin de sa vie que
quand on est au milieu c'est sans doute
un des pires défis du 21e siècle
pourquoi l'europe ne se fixerait tel pas
cette cause extraordinaire consistant à
se dire fédérons mettons ensemble tous
les laboratoires de recherche qui
travaille à l'échelle européenne
mettons les tous ensemble fixons leur
une grande cause d'intensifier nos
progrès et nos recherches contre les
maladies neurodégénératives fixons nous
cet enjeu de pouvoir dire demain que
l'europe et la fierté de dire nous qui
étions le continent de la famille
pasteur nous serons demain le continent
qui pourra dire au monde
nous avons permis de trouver les remèdes
contre la maladie d'alzheimer
voilà voilà la meilleure manière de dire
l'europe à laquelle nous croyons cette
europe mes amis c'est aussi celle de la
dignité c'est aussi celle qui sait que
dans une société tout ne peut pas finir
par être marchandisé c'est aussi celle
qui sait que l'être humain doit se fixer
des limites que la marchandisation du
corps humain que la marchandisation de
la procréation n'est pas une voie qui
est conforme à ce qu'est le destin et la
parole de l'europe
madame loiseau
fais partie de ceux qui défendent la
légalisation des mères porteuses en ce
qu on appelle ce qu'on appelle la
gestation pour autrui
il faut bien comprendre qu'à travers
elle c'est le lobby pro gestation pour
autrui qui exercera son influence au
parlement européen ceux qui acceptent un
marché de la personne humaine je ne peux
me résoudre ça n'est pas ma conception
de ce qu'est la civilisation européenne
de ce qu'est l'éthique de ce qu'est la
philosophie qui nous a portés et qui a
conduit à porter les bases de la dignité
humaine ce qui a été l'oeuvre patiente
de la civilisation européenne
eh bien nous nous battrons pour faire
interdire au niveau européen la
marchandisation du corps humain parce
que ça n'est pas conforme à ce qu'a été
l'europe et à ce qu'elle doit être
demain
[Applaudissements]
une civilisation enfin c'est une âme
c'est une culture c'est une histoire
comment ne pas voir aujourd'hui à quel
point nos civilisations et notre
civilisation peut être mortelle
au moment des gens qui sont pourtant nés
en france qui sont nés en europe
auxquelles la france et l'europe ont
tout donné
tourner leur haine et leur arme contre
tout ce que nous sommes et veulent
abattre ce que nous incarnons l'europe
doit se fixer une priorité cette
priorité c'est vaincre le totalitarisme
islamique vaincre le totalitarisme
islamique
il n'est même pas question de
l'islamisme à l'intérieur du programme
d' emmanuel macron comme si on avait
honte de mettre des mots sur les combats
que nous avons à mener
nous demandons au contraire que l'europe
puisse adopter un pacte européen contre
l'islamisme nous demandons que demain la
nouvelle majorité au parlement européen
puisse demander la fermeture de toutes
les mosquées salafistes qui sont en
europe
nous demandons que demain les imams qui
prêchent la haine soit reconduit hors
d'europe parce que nous devons arrêter
de les laisser faire leur travail de
propagande à l'ombre des mosquées et
nous demandons mes amis que la question
des djihadistes soit réglé dans la
clarté
je suis allé à mossoul dans le cadre du
programme que nous portons de soutien
aux minorités chrétienne en orient
j'ai échangé avec ces familles et idy
qui ont été réduits en esclavage sexuel
par les combattants de neige
j'ai vu dans mossoul cet immeuble qui
fait plusieurs étages et où ceux qui ne
partageaient pas leur fanatisme se
voyait mettre un sac sur la tête pour
être précipité dessus au dessous
building pour qu'ensuite ils agonisent
au pied de cet immeuble le cou brisé
j'ai vu ce terrain de foot où il faisait
jouer les gamins avec les têtes
décapitées de ce qui avait été leur
ennemi
cela c'est le jihad ces crimes et ces
barbaries qui ont été faites c'est
l'oeuvre des djihadistes et la france
notre gouvernement a accepté de faire
revenir 200 jihadiste sur le sol
français
eh bien nous ce que nous demandons ce
que nous portons c'est que l'europe
prenne la responsabilité d'organiser un
tribunal international en irak que ce
tribunal international juge en irak les
djihadistes qu elle les condamne là où
ils ont commis leur crime et qu'il reste
en irak et en syrie et qu'il ne revienne
pas sur le continent européen
car ils n'ont plus leur place en europe
car tout simplement l'islam politique
n'a pas sa place en europe
[Applaudissements]
mais si nous sommes honnêtes nous
portons une lourde responsabilité parce
que s'est il passé
le vide que nous avons laissé c'est
l'islam qui l'a occupé le vide que nous
avons laissé c'est l'islamisme politique
qu'il a occupé le vide que nous avons
laissé c'est le travail des intégristes
qui ont pris sous leur joug les
musulmans modérés
c'est nous qui l'avons mais c est que
s'est il passé
souvenez-vous de ce qu'est la véritable
histoire de l'intégration française et
je suis sûr que dans cette salle bien
des visages pourraient en témoigner
l'intégration de ce qu'était la
république française
c'était cette intégration merveilleuse
qui permettait à des gens qui arrivaient
dans notre pays de trouver leur place
parce qu'ils y venaient en disant à
leurs enfants
nous venons ici pour travailler à
compter de ce jour ne me fait pas honte
travaille dur à l'école ne te fait pas
remarquer apprend le français apprend à
lire et à écrire à compter de ce jour
ton pays c'est la france voilà ce
qu'était l'histoire de l'intégration
française
et nous nous avons inversé les choses et
nous nous avons inversé les choses
nous avons cru qu'il fallait inverser le
devoir d'intégration
nous avons cru que pour accueillir
l'autre il fallait que nous nous
adaptions nous avons cru que pour
intégrer l'autre il fallait que nous
adaptions notre propre mode de vie au
lieu d'avoir la générosité de dire voilà
comment nous fonctionnons et pour que
vous puissiez vivre dans le pays que
vous avez choisi il faut que vous
compreniez les règles qui sont les
nôtres
mes amis on a le droit d'aimer ce que
nous sommes
on a le droit de chérir ce que nous
sommes
je refuse que la france et l'europe
s'enfonce dans un déni de notre identité
et de notre culture qui nous a amenés
petit à petit a dénigré puisque nous
sommes je veux que nous retrouvions
cette fierté
je veux que nous retrouvions cette
fierté
comment ne pas comprendre comment ne pas
comprendre ce qui s'est joué qui était
si merveilleux dans cette souffrance et
cette épreuve qui était si terrible au
moment de l'incendié de notre dame
pourquoi tout le monde était touchée
mais parce que c'était la france qui
brûlait et parce que tout d'un coup et
est évident incontestable ce que nous
n'avions même pas eu le courage
d'inscrire dans les traités fondateurs
c'était la france et que l'on soit
chrétien ou non que l'on soit chrétien
musulman d'une autre religion
cette est évident qu'avec notre dame
c'est la france qui brûlait parce que
c'étaient nos racines chrétiennes qui
brûlait voilà pourquoi il faut ré
inscrire les racines chrétiennes dans
nos traités fondateurs
[Applaudissements]
mais ces incendies là sont visibles et
il ya d'autres incendies qui sont plus
invisible à chaque fois que l'on renonce
dans une classe d'histoire enseignés
soit l'histoire de l'europe soit
l'histoire de la shoah
7 un petit incendie à chaque fois que
dans un hôpital à chaque fois que dans
un hôpital un médecin homme se voit
contesté la possibilité d'intervenir sur
une patiente femme parce que son mari
explique que ce n'est pas compatible
avec sa religion
7 un petit incendie à chaque fois que
dans un quartier rachid à toi qui était
toujours engagé contre ça une femme n'a
plus le choix de la façon dont elles se
vêtit du choix professionnel qu'elle
fait 7
un petit incendie parce qu'en france et
en europe
une femme doit avoir le choix j'ai
toujours refusé de reculer sur la
question en apparence si anodine des
crèches
parce que j'ai toujours pensé que les
crèches c'était un petit bout de ce que
nous sommes et qu'à chaque fois que l'on
recule sur un petit bout de ce que nous
sommes nous abandonnons un grand pan de
notre civilisation il ne faut plus
reculées il ne faut plus se soumettre
saint-augustin le disait si bien à rome
fais comme les romains et bien
retrouvons ce qui est la si belle
histoire de l'intégration européenne et
française
revenons au bon sens c'est à celui qui
vient de s'adapter au mode de vie
européen et de respecter le mode de vie
européen
alors oui mes amis
il faut que nous retrouvions cette
fierté de notre histoire de notre
culture et de notre identité celle de
cette europe millénaire qui nous a
enchantés
cette europe qui arrête la barbarie aux
champs catalauniques quand les romains
et les français sont capables de s'unir
pour mettre un stop à l'invasion bâti
dans cette europe qui a couvert ses
paysages de ce manteau de clocher dhabi
qui font que quand on se déplace en
europe et qu'on voit ces silhouettes
familières qui nous parle on sait qu'on
est en europe cette europe gens qui a
porté la foi de l'homme jusque dans la
chapelle sixtine
quand elle est peinte par michel-ange
cette europe qui part à la découverte du
monde avec l'audace d'un magellan et la
splendeur de l'âge d'or espagnol
cette europe des philosophes et des
lumières qui a vu enfanté tout à la fois
montesquieu et quand cette europe qui a
crû dans la haie qui a foi dans le
progrès humain et dans la science celle
qui a ébahi le monde avec les travaux
dfl et de pasteurs cette europe qui
encore tente à dire et à apporter cette
europe qui nous raconte une histoire qui
est la nôtre
cette histoire dans nos pouvant tout à
la fois être fiers et dont nous pouvons
nous montrer dignes parce que quand on
est en france et en europe
la meilleure garantie de notre avenir ce
sont nos racines
la meilleure garantie de ce que nous
pourrons faire demain c'est ce que nous
sommes capables de transmettre à nos
enfants
réaffirmer l'identité européenne pour
retrouver le sens de notre civilisation
mes amis nous avons besoin de vous
françois xavier a besoin de vous il y a
un espoir qui s'est levé dans cette
campagne une force que personne ne
pourra arrêter
je vous demande de nous
et dans les deux jours qui restent
aidez-nous pour refonder l'europe et
pour rétablir la france je ne connais
pas en politique de plus grand ni le
plus beau combat
vive la france et vive l'europe
[Applaudissements]